6e 27 années la parole est à madame
bérengère poletti mme merci le sud
président monsieur le premier ministre
l'agriculture française et est leader en
europe
nous avons désormais reculé à la 3e
place pour les exportations européennes
la compétitivité de notre agriculture
est très faible comparée à celle de nos
voisins nos agriculteurs meurent en
silence parce qu'à l' inverse des autres
pays d'europe
les charges pèsent le plus lourdement
sur eux les contraintes sanitaires
environnementales économiques qu'on leur
impose sont plus lourdes près de la
moitié de nos éleveurs sont dans le
rouge
dans ce contexte déjà très difficile un
projet d'arrêté interministériel
envisagerait de durcir drastiquement les
règles d'application des produits
phytosanitaires on élargirait les zones
concernées de manière extrêmement
importante ces zones ne se limiterait
plus aux abords des points d'eau mais le
long des fossés le long des forêts le
long des bosquets le long des landes le
long des zones ont cultivé adjacente
c'est vrai il faut diminuer l'usagé des
produits phytosanitaires
mais ce qui se trame serait redoutable
pour l'agriculture française est d'une
grande brutalité 4 millions d'hectares
de surfaces impact et 7 milliards
d'euros de perte de chiffre d'affaires
par an rien que dans les ardennes
cela ferait perdre 15 à 20 % de terres
cultivables et ceci sans aucun
dédommagement
dans aucun pays en europe les
gouvernements n'impose cela à leurs
agriculteurs les mesures agro
environnementales et climatiques sont un
outil intéressant incitatif pédagogique
pour aboutir à cette transition
écologique nécessaire cependant tous les
agriculteurs n'y ont pas accès les aider
mal de 2016 n'ont d'ailleurs pas été
intégralement versé
aussi monsieur le premier ministre tout
pour ce sujet qui est un sujet agricoles
environnementales et sanitaires est
l'objet de réunions interministérielles
actuellement quand permettrait vous à
nos agriculteurs de travailler dans les
mêmes conditions que nos collègues
européens
merci la parole et à monsieur stéphane
le foll mais les agricultures de
l'agroalimentaire et de l'apport
le président a même la députée là encore
vous êtes en train de faire un tableau
je voudrais vous rappeler d'ailleurs que
la baisse la plus forte de la place de
la france dans les exportations
agricoles et agroalimentaires elle est
entre 2008 et 2012 que depuis un an je
vous le dis au passage nous avons
redressé augmenter nos exportations et
améliorer la balance commerciale
deuxième point madame la députée pour
que les choses soient claires simplement
quand nous sommes arrivés il y avait
autour de 750 millions de baisses de
charges pour les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui c'est 1 milliard 800
millions vous me parlez de la baisse des
charges
je vous donne des résultats les vôtres
et les nôtres donc il faut être honnête
entre nous et quand je vois d'ailleurs
que dans les débats que vous avez que
vous avez monsieur jacob monsieur
jacques je vous indique que avec moins
100 au moins 150 milliards de dépenses
publiques
je dis aux agriculteurs tout de suite il
risque de ne plus avoir de baisse de
cotisation 10 de cotisation là demain si
jamais bien sûr mais ça n'arrivera pas
vous gagneriez la présidentielle en face
sur la question de l'art était là encore
qu'est ce que je puis dire d'autre que
vous me parlez d'un arrêté qui n'existe
pas vous me faites une description
apocalyptique de ce qui se passerait si
y'avait l'arrêter tel que vous l'avez
quel est cet arrêté qui vous a donné
s'est arrêté la preuve c'est qu'il n'est
pas sorti s'est arrêtée puisque je n'ai
pas signé d'arrêter donc on ne parle
d'un arrêté j'ai bien compris comment ça
se passe je suis suffisamment bien
informés pour savoir quelquefois que on
peut engager des débats avec des arrêtés
qui sont et éventuellement discuter mais
il n'y a pas cet arrêté
l'objectif il est clair et je voulais
dit on aura à appliquer les lignes
directrices européennes qui s'applique
depuis 2016 vous êtes à la commission
des affaires sociales il pareil vous
occuper beaucoup de santé on doit tenir
compte de la santé de nos concitoyens
deuxièmement on doit tenir compte des
règles environnementales et
troisièmement on doit permettre aux
agriculteurs de travailler dans de
bonnes conditions
moi j'ai toujours été sur sept pays ça
m'a toujours été